during the covid19 crisis you've
probably heard one term
over and over again herd immunity
it happens when most of the population
becomes immune to an infectious disease
decreasing the health toll on a
population and the opportunities for the
virus to transmit
and thus survive we did it with measles
and mumps
and now we're figuring out how to get
there with the novel coronavirus
but one country is getting a lot of
press for aiming to get to herd immunity
faster sweden has taken a more low-key
approach to the pandemic
some u.s protesters have adopted sweden
as an example
sweden is prioritizing herd immunity and
some people are asking
why isn't the us following suit there
are two main ways of getting to herd
immunity
through widespread vaccination or
through natural infection and recovery
herd immunity requires at least 60 to 70
percent of people to achieve immunity
though some believe a 90 rate is needed
the herds immunity will help protect
those without immunity
an infected person would mostly come in
contact with immune people
stopping more infections the us
implemented lockdowns to slow the spread
while waiting for a vaccine the problem
with this method is that vaccine
development takes a long time
to be clear 18 months is the short end
of the vaccine timeline
dr fauci is hopeful that we can have one
in 18 months
but that would be a miracle i believe
because that would require
every single test of this vaccine to go
well
and have no safety problems and
sufficient immunity with that first
vaccine that we test i think that's very
unlikely
the kovid 19 virus is part of the same
coronavirus family that caused the early
2000s sars outbreak
so scientists have had a jump start but
even with the groundwork research done
and fast tracking of any trials it takes
time and exposure
to judge whether a vaccine is safe and
effective in the meantime
countries are forced to lock down in
physical distance in order to slow the
spread
and avoid overwhelming the health care
systems but the problems are two-fold
first physical distancing isn't as
effective as experts would like
in part because people have to be
vigilant numbers of cases are still
going up
that's not a recipe that says oh we can
relax and go back to work
second while the lockdown is happening
the economy is faltering
unemployment sits just below 15 with
millions of americans out of a job
protests have sparked demanding the
country reopen
and even still certain parts of the
country's hospitals
are filled mostly with covid19 patients
despite attempts to slow its spread
some have pointed to sweden's example of
what should have been done
which is the second path to hurt
immunity natural infection and recovery
we're not shutting down schools for
younger children or children's care
facilities
and we have no regulation that forces
citizens to remain
in their homes sweden didn't use
mandatory lockdowns
the swedish government did close some
schools and limited gatherings to less
than 50
but bars restaurants and gyms remain
open though
physical distancing is encouraged the
goal is to allow life to continue as
normally as possible
there's no enforcement of social
distancing by the police
and state mandated closures have been
minimal there are no
clear correlation between the lockdown
measures taken in countries
and the effect on on the pandemic
that was said in mid-april but now
countries that ease restrictions like
south korea and germany
are seeing spikes in cases critics argue
sweden is trying to achieve herd
immunity through a natural path
at the expense of its citizens and
though its health ministry says that is
not official policy
it's also saying that it's working
according to sweden's health ministry
over a quarter of stockholm's residents
show antibodies for covid19
the ministry predicts herd immunity of
60 will be reached by mid-may
however this method could overwhelm the
health care system
leading to many deaths depending on how
deadly the disease is
and the numbers in sweden paint a grim
picture a significant portion of the
country's deaths
have been in its nursing homes a fact
that the government admitted
was a failure in its strategy and the
death rate in sweden is almost
32 deaths per 100 000 people a number
significantly higher than its neighbors
and the us
even though it's lower than other
european countries like spain and italy
sweden's course could help its economy
recover quicker though like the rest of
the world
it's still suffering personally we
want the majority of our staff so
it's been difficult in many respects
natural immunity also requires infection
and recovery
but for a certain number there will be
no recovery
to reach the low end sixty percent of
americans or almost 200 million people
would have to be infected recover and
gain immunity
but this means one percent or nearly 2
million people would die
this using a 1 mortality rate trying to
get everybody sick
so that we achieve herd immunity i think
that's called nothing
beyond that there also isn't enough
information to know if recovery from
covid19
guarantees immunity from the virus when
a person recovers from a disease their
body usually builds a natural immunity
to fight future infection but immunity
from natural infection
has several different factors including
the amount of antibodies produced
whether those antibodies can defend
against a future infection and if so
how long will they provide immunity for
currently there are no studies proving
any of these with covid19 we can look to
other outbreaks in the coronavirus
family and develop educated guesses
but until then they are still at best
just educated guesses
[Music]
when dealing with a pandemic the paths
to herd immunity are not clean
both the u.s path and the swedish path
are a numbers game
one could lead to more deaths while the
other could have astronomical economic
impacts
and there is no one-size-fits-all path
even comparing u.s cities
doesn't quite work new york city is the
global hot spot
l.a often compared to new york suffered
relatively few deaths
but la is a city that sprawls spreading
its population out
whereas new york is dense causing less
room for physical distancing
dr fauci said a second wave is
inevitable
and as parts of the country reopen the
question is what can change to flatten
that second curve the best we can do
is learn from our past mistakes for when
it comes
take sweden while its deaths per 100 000
is higher than its neighbors
more than 87 percent of those deaths are
over the age of 70
a group known to be especially
vulnerable if a second wave comes
sweden needs to better protect that
population and in america
the unknowns will have to be known who
has it and recovered
are they immune now for how long can
those who've recovered from covet 19 go
back to work while the unprotected stay
isolated
during the first wave more than 80 000
people died in the u.s
as of may 11th americans can find a way
to do better
because what's at stake are the people
around us